Reckford: It is great to be with you all today.
Wonderful to be back on campus.
I've been on your side of the podium.
I think it's been a long time since I've been in this room.
Both when I was in your shoes a little bit excited, a little
bit anxious about
what the next steps might be as I got those coveted letters
MBA.
As Garth kindly pointed out, my education Stanford opened
doors for me to have
opportunities at a number of major companies.
But I would also say, as I look back, the story is not as
neat as it sounds in
the resume and I've encountered, just as all of you will,
bumps and bruises
along the way, challenges that challenged my resolve and
navigating those twist
and is turns that come along the way is a big part of our
collective challenge.
I love my work with Habitat. I feel greatly privileged to
get to be a part of
this mission and as I look back I can see how all the
different experiences
along the way helped prepare me, even if I couldn't see it
at the time.
I certainly don't pretend to have all the answers as to what
make AS great
leader but I can share a little bit of what I've observed.
Your experiences and your choices are gonna determine your
individual journeys
but I hope you can benefit a little from what I've seen both
from the roles of
some of the people I've had a chance to observe along the
way.
Like you, I've read books on leadership and collected my
share of quotes that
inspire me.
Among those, a clip by leadership expert John Maxwell, who
offers this tongue in
cheek encouragement.
"When you're getting discouraged as a leader," said John, "
think of Mosas.
He led a million complaining people for 40 years in the
desert and never arrived
where he was supposed to get.
Mosas faced a lot of complaints, criticism, and just plain
whining.
Some days as a leader I can sympathize with Mosas.
I bet if he had to do it all over again make a note to self.
Next time don't tell Pharaoh let all my people go."
>>
[Laughing]
Reckford: You know, leadership's hard and I think the more
people you attempt
to lead the harder it gets.
And Mosas is a good example.
As Garth laid the groundwork, I'm gonna share today in a
context of my personal
faith and -- because my story doesn't really make sense
without that but I hope,
regardless of your own faith perspectives, that the
principles behind it will
resonate with you today.
One of the first lessons -- and I doff around leadership --
is a common sense
one, is the importance of role models.
I think all successful leaders identify either individuals
or some composite of
individuals that they wanna emulate and they may be really
great bosses,
teachers, counselors, parents.
In my case I was blessed both with a mother who had a
ferocious sense of justice
and was very active in the civil rights movement and a
rather formidable
grandmother, a woman named Millicent Fenwick, who was a
human rights pioneer, a
New Jersey congresswoman who encouraged me and my siblings
at an early age to
think about what we were gonna do the serve the lost and
left out in the world.
Her words to be useful.
Walter Cronkite later called her the "Conscious of Congress.
"
I don't know how many of you have read the comic strip "
Doonesbury," the -- my
grandmother's often referred to for Garry Trudeau's
character Lacey Davenport in
the Doonesbury strips and she had a imposing regal presence
and prior to her
public career she had the unusual distinction of having
written "The Vogue Book
of Etiquette," which sold a million copies in 1948.
And so in order to graduate to the grownup table in grandma'
s house, you had to
be able to sit up straight, hold your fork properly, discuss
food problems in
sub Saharan Africa, which is both fascinating and terrifying
as a young child.
And she was intimidating but was also spiritual at her core
and almost every
time I would see her she would at some point drill in and
quote Micha six, six
through eight, from the Bible.
"He has shown you, oh man, what is good and what does the
Lord require of you
but to love mercy, to walk humbly with your God?"
So act justly, love mercy, and walk humbly with your God.
Pretty good marching orders for most of us and that's become
my life verse as
well, though it took a long time to grow into that.
I didn't come to Stanford right after college.
My original plan of going into -- going to law school then
into politics got
derailed when I discovered I had no actual interest in
practicing law so I had
to come up with plan B and talk my way into a job at Goldman
Sachs.
Despite the latest images, this is a tough month for that
company.
Uh, one of the most important lessons I learned early was
from one of the
co-leaders of Goldman at that time, a man named John
Wineberg, and there were a
lot of less senior people in the firm who were caught up in
their own power and,
uh -- but John Wineberg took a personal interest in
virtually everyone and he
had a deep, personal respect for everybody in the firm and
that's been something
that's been critical to me to watch both for people I was
gonna potentially work
with or for, or also now when I'm hiring people to see, how
do they behave
towards the receptionist or the custodian, or people that
don't have potential
positive influence for them as a sign of character.
And not everyone will agree but to me a sort of core tenet
of leadership is that
fundamental respect for all people in organizations.
I wasn't a great fit as a financial analyst.
I was a poly sci English major with no accounting or finance
preparation and had
to suffer hard to live up to the idea.
I sold myself into the idea that I could learn finance
faster than they could
teach someone to communicate.
I'm not sure it was totally true.
>>
[Laughing]
Reckford: And I found it really intellectually interesting
but not very
emotionally satisfying and was living in New York City, in
Time Square and sort
of juxtaposition of walking by these huge numbers of
homeless people in the
morning and evening against the sort of big mergers and
acquisitions and
financing deals, uh, I think caused me to do some hard
thinking.
And I also had a growing sense of a disconnect between the
life I'd imagined
living and the way I was actually spending my time at that
point.
And so felt -- I'd become very interested in business along
the way but felt it
needed to go off and have an adventure and was lucky enough
to get the luge
program and the -- no, to put the coaching in perspective,
they only qualified
because they were the host team and there were some
parallels to the Jamaican
bobsled team but we did beat the Japanese.
So for those of you who know Asia, that was significant.
And it was a -- it was a huge life experience for me as an
emersion experience.
I was living in the Korean training camp with all the
coaches and athletes and
the only other non Korean I got to see was a Russian boxing
coach who was also
in the dormitory.
And it's sort of unfathomable to most of you a world with no
internet, no e-mail
and staggeringly expensive phone calls.
So really quite isolated from -- from all my relationships.
And so it gave me a lot of time to read, and think and
reflect.
And the only westerner I saw on a regular basis was a man
named Jim Peterson who
was the other luge scholar that happened to be placed in
Korea that year and he
was a pastor and ethics professor teaching at one of the
great Korean
universities.
And Jim was one of those rare people who had both the
intellectual rigor to go
as deep as I could go theologically and at the same time --
which really caught
my attention -- an inner peace and a quiet confidence that I
think really
contrasted I think to my sort of raw ambition and need to
impress people.
And Jim took the time to get to know me and then made really
a quite
extraordinary offer.
He offered me the -- all of his Monday nights for the rest
of that year and we
ended up spending three to five hours every Monday night
walking throughout
Bible and doing systematic theology, so I had my private
seminary.
And I think for some people you all have your own
experiences, faith can be sort
of a burning bush event.
Less so for me.
I had to have that integration of head and heart so it was a
very gradual
process that eventually got me to -- S?ren Kierkegaard calls
that leap of faith
but it was finally -- became clear to me that the kind of
life I wanted to lead
was one of faith and that was 1987 and I think for me hasn't
necessarily made
life easier but unquestionably made life better and richer.
And so my time at Korea was coming to an end I applied to
business schools with
the thought -- and Stanford was the cutting edge of this --
that the skills I
could acquire in the business world were desperately needed
in the non profit
and service world as well and Stanford was very intriguing
to me because the
public management program was integrated into the regular
business curriculum.
It -- while at Stanford, I got interested in business
strategy and how
organizations grow.
And after graduation, again, you have to choose your job
criteria, my most
important criteria was to get to Washington, D.C. where my
then girlfriend, now
wife, Ashley was.
So I had a chance to work with Marriott working on new
business development in
their strategic planning group and had chance to -- was
enjoying it very much --
helped work on the launch of their senior living service,
their adult care
business, and got married, got promoted, life was good.
And then we -- it pales in comparison, the S&L crisis hit.
So for those of you historians, it was not a great -- not as
bad as now but was
not a great time for the financial world.
Marriott actually nearly went bankrupt and made significant
cuts that included
our strategic planning team and me and it was a little
shocking to be laid off.
I was newly married and I'd lost my job and even though it
was sort of perfectly
explicable, it was hard not to feel a little bit rejected.
And turned out fine.
I was -- had the chance to start up a strategic planning
group for the real
estate arm of Disney which was a really fun and interesting
experience.
Got to work on great projects and I think Disney taught me a
lot about being a
fanatic about great customer service which I really
appreciate.
But there was another side of Disney which I appreciate a
little less and that
was sort of the Burbank studio culture at the time and one
of the former execs I
won't name was very well known and behaved for quotes like
this, "If you don't
come in on Saturday, don't bother coming in on Sunday."
Or --
>>
[Laughing]
Reckford: Or a little more frightening, though humorous, "
other companies do
good cop bad cop.
We do bad cop Antichrist.
."
>>
[Laughing]
Reckford: And it was not good to apologize at the beginning
of a negotiation to
an outside party for the inherent unreasonableness of our
position.
But it is, umm -- it leads to lesson No. 3 which is, you
have to be very careful
about becoming a leader or working in a place that doesn't
operate in sync with
your personal values and that means -- obviously that starts
with having to know
your personal values and as I was sort of struggling with
the implications of
this ask sort of what kind of career I could have there, a
headhunter called
with an opportunity to come to Circuit City, and there was
correlation but not
causality that there was two companies I worked for don't
exist anymore but --
>>
[Laughing?]
Reckford: Circuit City was on top of the world then.
They'd been the fastest growing company on the stock
exchange for the entire
1980s and they had just started CarMax.
You may not be too familiar.
It was the -- it revolutionized the used car business.
It was the first time anyone had ever offered warrantied,
fixed price,
returnable used cars and I thought that was really
interesting.
So we moved to Richmond, Virginia and I never intended to be
in retail but found
the work really interesting, learned a lot, but had a
growing -- had a growing
desire to actually -- to run something at this point and I
had lots of business
development work.
And so after four years, phone rang again and quite
unexpected and this was
Musicland which is about a 2 million-dollar retailer at the
time, back when
people actually bought music and movies on plastic discs,
which is another thing
that's hard to believe, and we were the leading mall
retailer of entertainment
products and it is a disappearing category.
And Napster had just launched so they could see the future
and offered me a
chance to run the operations and help navigate a -- a new
path for the company.
I can't say my wife was terribly enthused.
She couldn't really understand why God would want a nice
southern lady to move
to Minneapolis, the land of endless winter and, uh -- but I
had a very strong
sense of what we were supposed to do and she -- she
grudgingly agreed so we made
the move.
We actually had a couple of record years and yet one of the
more discouraging
things from a business perspective, it was very hard to see
how the company
could survive not just against the brick and mortar but
against the inevitable
digital transformation that was coming.
So we ended up selling the company to Best Buy which was a
great win for our
shareholders and a great lost really for our -- ultimately
for our staff and for
Best Buy.
It was not a great acquisition.
And I stayed for a year to help try to make the acquisition
work but also then
became clear that -- that I was redundant with the --
appropriately put in Best
Buy head of the division.
And so Best Buy was kind enough to offer different
opportunities but I had a
growing sense that it was time -- it had taken much longer
than I has expected
and maybe this is the time to begin the transition that I'd
always planned of
the nonprofit world.
And I'd been increasingly passionate about some of the -- my
volunteer work,
which had been helping coach pastors and priests in the
leadership side of
churches.
And so even though I regularly counsel people, don't leave
without knowing what
your next step is in this case made a decision to jump and
took off with some
big ideas and a really ferocious non-compete clause but I
did have a walk away
package so it was not a particularly brave move.
For us, the freedom meant that I was gonna have a lot of
time with, at that
point, our very young children at home with Ashley and time
to have a little
enough space to really think about the next step.
A little while after that Ashley had encouraged me to do
something I had never
really had time to do and always wanted to do which is to go
on an international
mission trip and I know many of you have done this now -- or
service trip. I
wanted to go to Uganda, where our church had been sponsoring
all the AIDS
orphans in the Rakai district where AIDS really broke out.
But I was too late to join that trip and ended up, through a
series of events,
being able to join an opportunity to serve with the Dalats
in central India.
And the Bungi -- the Dalats are commonly known as the
untouchables or the
traditional outcasts in Indian community and the Bungi are
sort of the bottom of
the bottom of the social pecking order, literally only aloud
to clean latrines
and clean up after dead animals and living in conditions
that really
unimaginably bad and about half the kids without some kind
of intervention are
dying by the age of 13 from a combination of poor nutrition
and poor health.
And I think for me, uh, just shattered me to see people
living in these
conditions and it was -- I don't know that I knew but I
essentially after a
couple weeks there came back with a pretty strong sense that
I was -- it was
time to spend the rest of my time doing something to help
the poor.
And I think for me it reignited some of those early passions
around social
justice that had softened down a little bit over the years.
It was what Bill Hybels, pastor of the Willow Creek Church,
calls a holy
discontent.
That was a nicely-termed phrase.
And we have plenty of discontent in our society.
We see it all over the place.
People are watching some terrible event unfold in their
community of the world
and the response is, that's terrible.
Somebody ought to do something about that and they change
channels, watch
"American Idol".
And a holy discontent and contrast is when you or I see
those terrible events
unfold in our community of the world and the response is, I
can't stand that and
I'm gonna do something about it.
You turn off the TV, and get off the couch and get into the
community and decide
to be making -- try to make the world a little bit better.
It's -- so I came back with a new passion but not a very
clear direction.
And what was -- took me back for the first time really in my
whole life suddenly
all the doors are closing.
And now I can look back and see none of those were really
the right things but
got to the finals of a couple of different really exciting
nonprofit jobs and
didn't get them.
And I think we MBAs are particularly at risk of defining
ourselves what we do.
So when people would ask the inevitable question, I had a --
sort of a matter of
discipline to bite my tongue and resist the urge to say, "I
used to be XYZ" or
"I used do XYZ" and just say that, you know, I was home with
my family and
trying to figure out what I was supposed to do next.
And I'm not a particularly patient person so I didn't --
waiting isn't very easy
for me and I think when you wait and question it can drive
you a little bit nuts
for us type A types.
And when I first left Best Buy turned down some very good
business jobs, then I
started wondering, did I get the signals wrong?
Did I miss -- miss the opportunity?
And in the meantime I was cranking way up on my volunteer
time both with our
kids at their school and at church and quite unexpectedly
the -- all the
leadership development work I was doing at our very large
church ended up with
the church asking me to run the church as executive pastor,
to free up the
pastor to just preach and teach.
And it was not what I was looking to do and most of my
friends thought this was
a really bad career move, and would not be a smart thing to
do.
But as best we could tell -- best I could tell, it was what
I was supposed to
do.
So went into full-time church work and in fact loved it and
it was a great time
for our family and it was -- it was a very fulfilling time
for me and I was not
actually looking when probably the most important phone call
I've gotten came in
and it was from a partner at Spencer Stuart, who had
recruited me in the past,
who asked, Jonathan, do you know anybody who'd be interested
in CEO for Habitat
for Humanity?
And, uh, a chill went down my spine and I asked a little bit
shyly, "Does it
have to be somebody famous?"
And, uh, and then went home and wrote a very passionate
letter about why this
was the kind of thing I had been preparing for for the last
many years.
And I felt like finally here was something that really
combined all of my
passions and put everything together.
It was, for me, very much my dream job and I really wanted
it very badly, did
not expect to get it, and was very surprised and delighted
to -- to have the
chance.
And I -- that's a lot of detail but I wanted -- I share that
because the fourth
lesson I would share is, you know, my dad was a teacher and
he taught one place
for 45 years and then retired.
I think that world is changed, I think in the business world
especially, careers
are enormously more fluid than they used to be.
And -- but I wanna encourage you is to -- is to not fight
the detours along the
way, and particularly to take advantage of learning from the
white spaces in
your -- in your career and the failures which I often found
were the richest
learning times for me.
I arrived at a really critical inflection point for Habitat
in many ways.
Like very successful startup companies, they were in the
process of
transitioning from a highly charismatic entrepreneurial
founder and had grown
far bigger than they'd ever imagined and needed, in the
board's view, more
professional management to build out a sort of
infrastructure and leadership
team to support this exponential growth that they'd had
around the world.
Habitat needed to become more sufficient, more sustainable,
and more equipped to
be able to continue to sustain the growth given how much --
the side of the need
in virtually every country in which we serve.
I think many of you -- I presume all everyone's familiar
with Habitat but let me
give you just a quick Habitat 101 class.
Most importantly, we build houses in partnership with -- not
for -- families who
need decent and affordable homes in the U.S. and across the
world.
We don't give the houses away.
Homeowners make a down payment and purchase their homes from
us on a no profit
basis.
Homeowners are selected based on three core criteria.
First, need, they wouldn't be otherwise able to obtain a
home loan or mortgage;
second, the ability to re-pay a very affordable no-profit
mortgage over a 30-to
50-year period; and three, the willingness to partner with
Habitat.
And for us, partner means is willingness to put hundreds of
hours of sweat
equity into building their home and helping build other
people's homes, and also
to go through financial and home management training in
preparation for
homeownership.
In the same way, then, their mortgage payments revolve in
the community so in
addition to recipients, they become donors to help other
families have a chance
at homeownership.
As a Christian ministry now working into our fourth decade,
we've got a pretty
good idea what to expect when a family gets, for the first
time, a decent place
to live.
We see huge impacts on health, the children go up -- growing
up in decent homes
have much better health outcomes; healthy children have much
better educational
outcomes; and in addition to the sort of physical and
material benefits of
homeownership, there's a huge psychological change that
happens as well when a
people have a place to call home.
And what we've seen over and over again is family members
are so proud of their
new houses their homes become social centers, they become
anchors in the
community to stabilize communities, and many communities
have been lifted from
forgotten blighted areas to areas that have been restored
and become inviting
areas.
In fact now with the housing crisis, purchasing up these
empty, foreclosed homes
has become a high priority for us.
So we're shifting our mix more away from new home
construction towards rehabbing
empty homes and in that and around those rehabbed homes
tearing down the worst
ones, building targeted new ones, and then doing
weatherization and repairs to
preserve homeownership, especially for the elderly and those
communities in that
trying to do as much as we can to revitalize whole
communities versus individual
homes.
That's a Habitat model.
It's a model that's been effective now for well over 30
years.
As Garth said, last year we helped over 61,000 families
through a mix of new
homes and rehabs and major repairs, which was at almost
triple where we were
five years ago.
The nonprofit world is at least as complex from a management
perspective as
anything I found in the business world.
We have over 1500 affiliates in the U.S. which goes back to
that Mosas quote.
I think the -- I once had a reporter from the New York Times
say this big change
we're putting in had caused 12 affiliates to get upset.
And I just laughed.
I thought, if there was anything we ever did that only 12
affiliates were upset
at we would be doing Hallelujahs.
But when you add that together, we're actually the largest
home builder in the
United States.
We serve in over 80 countries.
If you pulled all the Habitat budgets together it's about a
billion and a half
in terms of total revenue and we increasingly are able to
play a significant
role in terms of shaping housing policies around the world
as well.
Stanford stood for the idea, although I look back to Ernie
Arbuckle that the
same skills that will make you successful in the for-profit
world are needed in
the nonprofit world.
And I took that seriously but I can tell you, it is more
true than ever now and
I think it's a much more widely accepted idea now as well.
I know certainly we're being called to use those skills.
We've set a new goal now at Habitat to serve a hundred
thousand families per
year by 2013 which is gonna challenge us to find new ways to
scale up and
increase our impact in the communities in which we serve.
And I feel very blessed to have a small role in that
process.
I have the -- the sad part of my job is I continue to travel
across the world to
places and see the way the families live all across the
world and it is truly
heartbreaking still and you know the numbers.
But I've also had the chance to see what just as we call a
hand up, not a hand
out, can do to let a family lift themselves out of poverty
and the fundamental
difference that can make in life.
Last year I looked into the eyes of a six- girl in a small
town in El Salvador
who told me her dreams of being a lawyer so she could help
others.
Her mother was already living her dream.
She'd always wanted to be a hairdresser and have her own
salon but had never had
the chance.
And now she'd opened a salon in her new Habitat home as soon
as the girls who
can now go to school went off, she started treating
customers and she's able to
earn an income and spend the time with her girls.
In Vietnam last fall I met a family 51-year-old grandfather
who had literally
spent his entirely living on a boat with his extended
family.
We have the privilege of tucking our children into bed.
They would tie the children in at night because they'd lost
one grandchild to
drowning in bad weather.
And if you could see the boat, uh, or the boats these
families were living in,
it would just -- it would just break your heart.
And I had the privilege of dedicating with them -- we talk
about a house being
the foundation for a decent life.
This family, for the first time ever, was gonna have a
foundation and live on
dry land which meant their kids can now go to school,
unbelievable health
impacts for -- for them and for their future.
So my days don't get much better than that.
And a quick review.
The leaders I've respected the most have emulated good role
models and picked
the right ones; they respect and value all of their staff
and teams; they find a
place that -- to work that is in sync with their defined
personal values; and
they remain adaptable and as eager to learn from their
failures as their
successes.
I think for me, when I look back on the story, my life
changed dramatically for
the better during one of the sort of quiet times in life
when I wasn't earning a
dime and probably was the most frustrated and I don't think
I could have ever
charted the path the led to Habitat.
If I -- I wouldn't have been ready for this role if I had
come straight from
Best Buy and I also know if I had taken the job at the
church just so I could
get a job like Habitat, I'm fully convinced that never would
have worked.
It is -- in my experience, the times that I really loved
work were was when I
was really focused on getting projects done or doing
something that mattered and
the least successful were those when I was focused on trying
to grow my career.
And my hope for all of you is that you'll find the same
satisfaction. I hope
and pray that each of you will find a vocation that allows
you to take your
gifts and skills and passion and do something, whether in
the private sector or
the nonprofit world, that makes the world a little bit
better.
I think we all get bombarded constantly and you all are and
will continue to be
bombarded with definitions of the good life that base
everything based on the
size of your salary and the house you live in, the car you
drive, how much
plastic surgery you've had, how perfect you look.
And I think it brings me to the final lesson.
When, as you get increasing responsibilities in leadership,
I think you'll be
awash in temptations and I think you gotta be very
intentional in defining what
a good life is for you and be -- in pursuing it because the
lure of letting
other people define that for you is very tempting.
And it's very easy for all of us to get our egos and
identities tied up with our
jobs or mixed up with our jobs and I find I can be more
careful than ever now
that I'm in a comparatively public position.
As a son of a classics professor, I think we all need to be
careful of the idea
of hubris, that idea of putting ourselves on par with the
gods.
When I see the things that blow leaders up, and usually it's
around money, sex,
and power, they're really all wrapped up in pride and you
have to be aware of
those temptations and I think the ones who say, that could
never happen to me,
that's often the first step down that path.
And I've seen some dear friends and otherwise really
effective and great leaders
totally derail not only their careers but their families
because they weren't
aware of those temptations or didn't think it could happen
to them.
In my experience it's better to be humble than to be
humbled.
And I don't think you have to think of humility as a
limitation. Jim Collins,
who was a GSB entrepreneur ship professor back when we were
here before he
became a guru, discovered the idea of a level five leader in
his research and I
was so pleased to see that and that idea of people that had,
as he would say, a
paradoxical combination of personal humility and fierce
ambition for their
mission or cause.
Not that level five leaders have no ego or self-interest.
In fact, they're incredibly ambitious but it's their
ambition for what they're
trying to get done rather than for themselves.
And tied to that is integrity, which we just see over and
over again can be
destroyed in an instant.
Warren Bennis, another leadership guru, describes
effectively leadership as a
carefully-balanced three-pronged stool of ambition,
confidence, and a moral
compass.
And sadly, we can't watch the businesses these days without
seeing what happens
when you have destructive achievers, high ambition, high
competence, and no
moral compass.
And, uh, leadership ultimately comes -- starts or emanates
from character and
character comes from a Greek word that literally means a
tool that marks or
engraves us.
And each day, each choice, each action we make we're in the
constant process of
either making or unmaking our character either moving more
towards the kinda
person we wanna be or moving back and it's ultimately how
our colleagues and
others are gonna measure us.
So you have to choose those values you're gonna live by,
you've gotta choose the
lines that you're not willing to cross before those
situations actually come
along.
And, uh, and finally, you gotta -- you've gotta lead from
passion, not just from
position.
And I hope -- I didn't always know.
I certainly had lots of passion but very little focus and I
hope you all can
find that area of passion for you.
What is that issue, that problem, that thing in society that
you look out and
upsets you or you think could be done better or could be
fixed?
What's your holy discontent?
And that might be your first clue as to what your calling
is.
Frederick Beekner, theologian, says, "Calling is where the
deep gladness of your
heart meets the world's great need."
And I think it's worth -- take some reflection to put those
together but if you
can, then you'll be ready when the right phone rings or when
that right call
comes.
So what are your dreams?
What problems do you wanna solve?
What price are you willing to pay to, uh, to make that
happen?
So we close and I hope to turn into a conversation.
I just wanna share my favorite blessing from the Franciscan
tradition.
"May God bless you with discomfort at easy answers, half
truths, and superficial
relationships so that you may live deeply within your heart.
May God bless you with anger at injustice, oppression, and
exploitation of
people so that you may wish for justice, freedom, and peace.
And may God bless you enough foolishness to belief that you
can make a
difference in this world so that you can do what others say
cannot be done."
It's great to be with you.
Thank you.
>>
[Clapping]
Reckford: I think we have time for some questions and I
think they asked if
people would wait for the mic to be passed down so they can
capture them so
everybody can hear.
>>
[Quiet]
Audience: Well, thank you for coming.
I wanted to ask a question going back to the sale of
Musicland.
Seems like you had some constituents there with competing
interests between
shareholders and your team and maybe even customers and I
was curious how your
faith and how Christian principles formed how you balanced
those interests, and
in particular, was it difficult for you to reconcile the
sale of an asset that
it seems like you had some suspicions was a failing asset
and maybe the sale
wouldn't go well?
Reckford: You know, I think -- the interesting thing was
that Best Buy had a
hypothesis that turned out to be flawed but they had a model
of using the real
estate in a huge number of relationships with had with teens
in malls to
leverage those for electronics sales and so it was a
plausible strategy of why
it was gonna be different than -- it was gonna migrate
around music, umm, and
didn't work.
But we -- I think were more -- they were way more optimistic
and we were more
optimistic at the time, umm, that that was actually the best
path because
otherwise we could see sort of a long eroding tale where we'
d just be closing
stores as leases came up because retail, you know, the
leverage is so strong
that relatively small decreases in sales wipe out all your
profitability very
quickly, uh, so it's a very thin business.
So it -- but I think it is, you know, much easier to look
back now with all the
data than -- than when you're looking forward but Best Buy
was on a roll and
they had the financial strength to underwrite the sort of
revamping of the
stores that we didn't have the capital to do.
So it struck us at the time as sort of the best option for
everybody. Everybody
should go through a merger.
Being acquired once, it's an incredible education.
I think the danger of -- of almost every acquisition is,
even if they're done
for strategic purposes and you acquire because you want the
skills and gifts of
the group you're acquiring, there's an acquirer's bias that
I've seen whether I
was in the investment banking side or on the operating side
where the acquirer
tends to think they have always answers so they, uh, I think
Best Buy made some
major strategic mistakes by not fully understanding what,
uh, the assets they
were buying before they put all the changes in place.
But it's -- I think it's a -- it's a constant juggling act
of all those stake
holders.
>>
[Quiet]
Audience: Umm, well, thanks also for coming.
I think a lot of times ministry organizations have a lot of
difficulty in the
management of people, how they hire, how they fire, how they
grow.
Many times they can't fire just out of obligation or out of,
I don't know,
some -- can you just kinda talk about how you've managed
Habitat if you've seen
some of those issues when you come in and how you're gonna
grow and build the
business go forward?
Reckford: Thank you.
It's -- it's really interesting challenge I think and
actually it was so --
that's part of why it was so valuable to work in a church
environment before
coming to Habitat.
If you want the most complex management challenge in some
ways try to manage a
synagogue, or a mosque, or a church because you've got
immense ownership, all
volunteers, very little leverage over the people doing all
the work and, uh, and
an enormous shared ownership of the mission.
So they're great assets but great complexity as well.
What I found is, umm, that was really helpful to learn is
you can manage
volunteers and if you can manage volunteers you can -- it's
much easier to
manage people but, umm, we learned that you can hold
volunteers accountable,
that you, uh, that actually you need to do the same work to
make sure that a
volunteer is in a role that he or she values and uses their
gifts well.
One of the things that faith groups do poorly is often they'
ll put very high
capacity people and put them in the wrong roles and Habitat
was doing the same
thing.
And so, uh, the second thing I learned is that you're not,
umm, you're not doing
someone a favor by letting them sit in the wrong role not
being successful.
That's bad for the mission and actually bad for the
individual.
And so, uh, I was sharing with a group last night, you know,
I think what I had
to learn was, umm, that it has to be integrated.
I got pushed, you know, often as we put in change and sort
of raise
accountability, that got thrown back as, well, you're not
being faithful anymore
and sort of either we were gonna be grass root and is
faithful or we were gonna
be professional and that was termed as "going corporate" and
that was viewed as
a bad thing.
And the response was, no.
We're using other people's money to do God's work to serve
the poor of the
world.
We should have much higher standards than the private sector
because the
standards are so high.
So we're gonna be unapologetic about accountability and much
of the practice we
do if we standard any well-run organization I hope in terms
of making sure
everyone has very clear roles, very clear responsibilities,
they know what
they're supposed to be accountable for, then we reward them
for doing their
work.
It's, umm, I think it's hard, though, because there's that
whole being nice.
You know, anybody here from Minnesota?
So there's, you know, they call Minnesota nice so the land
of -- the land of
Lutherans and woe begotten where nobody wants to say the
hard things and I think
part of, uh, my view is, it's not -- again, you don't have
to be nice or, you
know, bad cop Antichrist model, that there's a -- that you
can be nice and --
and be really clear and transparent and sometimes there's a
-- the other thing
we see in nonprofits is -- the thing is in nonprofit
management is you get two
groups in nonprofits.
One group who are people with world class skills and gifts
and talents and who
are there because of the mission and I think there's another
group, umm,
sometimes who are there, you know, somewhat as refugees or
to be rescued rather
than -- rather than to, uh, to make a difference and that's
really hard.
And it is, umm -- what we found is we wanna treat people
respectfully, we wanna
treat people well, up, but at the end of the day, the first
thing is the mission
and what we can't do is allow somebody who's not performing
well because if --
if you send a signal that it's okay not to perform well,
that starts sort of
demotivating your high performing folks and pulling them
down.
But it's not easy.
Audience: Hi.
Thanks.
One of the things I've been most impressed about is your
ability to scale over
the last five years.
Can you talk about what are some of the levers that you
pulled to be able to do
that in the nonprofit world and what are some of the
challenges you face going
forward as you look at taking it to the next level?
Reckford: Thank you.
It's, umm, you know, some things -- true, every organization
the best ideas are
all at the field level so we certainly didn't come in and
say, here are all the
great new ideas. We actually -- I traveled around the world
and just looked for
what was -- what was working or what were all the things
people were secretly
doing but didn't -- you know, weren't saying because they
didn't think that
would be okay back at headquarters and we tried to get
permission to -- and a
couple things particularly drove growth.
One, right as I started, Katrina hit, which was not on my
hundred day plan but
it freed us up to break a lot of rules in terms of doing
something -- and we
needed to do something big by our standards in the Gulf so
it forced us to sit
down and sort of reassess the model of how can we do enough
to matter in that --
in that?
So we got the board to formally bless disaster recovery as a
formal part of our
work which had been informally there for a wile.
And we used the tsunami in Asia and Katrina in the U.S. as
models of scaling up.
We ended up helping 23,000 families in the tsunami which is
bigger than anything
we had ever done and we were the leading -- we may still be
the leading home
builder in the -- in the Gulf Coast since Katrina which,
again, is not a typical
role for Habitat.
But in doing that, we used that to learn how to move faster
and to do whole
community development and operated to scale and operate in
partnerships in way
that is we hadn't before.
So now Haiti and Chile, we're doing -- we're gonna try to
help 50,000 families
in Haiti and a similarly large number we hope in Chile over
time.
So disaster response was big.
The second one was housing micro finance, uh, and micro
finance extremely well
established but almost -- almost 90 to 95 percent of the
people in the world
have no access to a home loan of any kind and so what we're
-- in addition to
all the -- so we do housing lending out of necessity but it'
s not our
preference.
So one of our goals is to get the micro finance world to
begin lending for home
improvement loans to families that have been taking out
successful small
business loans and we're, umm, that's been a -- we see that
as a huge next scale
up.
We're launching a global housing micro finance fund to be a
wholesale lender to
MFIs and then we'll technical assistance if they'll do the
lending.
And that's -- we see that as one of our next big bridges for
scale.
Uh, and then the third one would be around advocacy, umm,
trying to actually
change policies so we can impact way more people than the --
than the houses we
build and our big focus is on secure tenure and property
rights especially for
women in developing countries.
So we're trying to change rules to, uh, create protections
and, again, if we
can, use crises to do that.
So we're doing big projects around HIV, widows and orphan
programs in Africa,
particularly in southeast Asia.
In India and the tsunami, we used the -- so the chance to
come in and serve we
titled all the homes along the southeast Indian coast and
women's names only and
got the other nonprofits to do the same thing.
That actually had a pretty profound social change in terms
of -- of changing,
uh, changing the values there.
So -- and similarly, in Africa in a lot of countries if a
woman's husband dies,
his husband inherits the property and the women and children
are left out.
So we're trying to get laws changed to allow joint titling
and so we see the --
the ability to allow families to stay in communities as a
way we can scale way
beyond our -- our core building.
That's a few of 'em.
>>
[Quiet]
Audience: Thank you very much for coming.
Umm, I worked in the nonprofit sector before coming to
business school and was
given the advice by somebody, umm, excuse me, at the
millennium challenge
corporation who had gone directly from business school back
to the NCC that had
she -- to do it over again, she really would have gone to
the private sector
before going to the nonprofit sector.
And I'm wondering if you can speak a little bit about --
although your intention
was clear to go to -- to, umm, Goldman Sachs, what you
learned in all of those
years in the private sector that has made you more effective
if your current
role.
Reckford: You know, I -- it's a really good question.
We were actually talking about it right before this session.
I don't think there's a right or wrong rule.
Umm, I think there are enormous benefits to getting private
sector experience
and I think there are -- if you were to generalize and I
think there are
brilliantly run nonprofits that are better than -- than most
companies and then
there are a lot of poorly-run -- awful lot of poorly-run
nonprofits that are out
there likewise there are a lot of well-run companies and not
so well-run
companies.
So you need to choose carefully.
I think for me my hypothesis was I would get more experience
faster in the
business world then could take that with me.
I think what I would temper that with is a means to an end.
I wouldn't take a job that you really don't wanna do just so
you can get to
something else 'cause I think the chance of being successful
aren't as good.
And I think there are great individual opportunities.
If you take an organization -- take something Muhammad Yunus
or Fazle Abed and
BRAC-- you know, if you could work with a leader like that,
that would dwarf any
business leader you could ever find in terms of staggering
entrepreneurial
talent.
But those are -- but you have to find the right leader to
attach yourself to.
So I think it's -- it's my view is I would explore both
paths if your passions
are leading you that way and then pick, umm, you know, the
place you think
you're gonna get the highest learning curve and -- and the
most tangible
experience in the -- in the shorter term.
And then you've got a way in sort of the golden hand cuffs
trap of once -- a lot
of people go in saying they're gonna do this and then they
never actually make
the move and 25 years later they have all these regrets and
they weren't that
happy or fulfilled.
So it's a -- I think you have to be careful.
>>
[Quiet]
Audience: Do we have time for one more question?